[Music]
Outlander co-stars Katrina belf and Sam
heughan adorably pose it up in LA ET was
with the actor and actress who played
Claire and Jamie on the hit star show at
W magazines pre Golden Globe party on
Thursday I'm just really excited I mean
it's it's really amazing to be here I
think it's gonna be really special
who are you rooting for exam in the
Golden Globes I mean there's only one
vote the rating matters
it's my co-star Gina Bob if she doesn't
win I'm gonna burn the whole a down I'm
looking forward to seeing my co-star get
between about the gold the Irish actress
is nominated for Best Actress in a TV
series drama
as for what she'll be wearing on Sunday
I'm gonna look at some stuff tomorrow
and hopefully things have arrived from
New York so there's a big storm so who
knows I could be in a in a no plastic
bag but are you planning to wear back
yes I am meanwhile Sam gave us a sneak
peek of the show's upcoming season for
Bernie short for episodes I'm not about
to give away too much but I will let you
know that we are both alive and didn't
die in the storm and did we mention he's
Katrina's biggest fan
give Katrina both the gold piece just
give it a card that's a weaker
[Music]